as we celebrate the golden anniversary
of the protein data bank
let's look at the history and the
milestones that shaped it to become the
essential resource for research and
education
it is today the protein data bank was
established in 1971. in its first few
years the archive was very small
and contained a few groundbreaking
structures
for each structure the pdb contained the
three-dimensional coordinates
or the x y and z positions of each atom
how did the scientists see the atoms
back in the 1970s the sole method to do
so was x-ray crystallography
proteins form crystals when they are
purified and concentrated
within the crystal many copies of the
protein are arranged in symmetrical
arrays
when an x-ray beam strikes the crystal
the x-rays scatter into a distinctive
pattern of spots
these x-ray diffraction patterns are
then analyzed to determine the positions
of atoms in the protein
in 1913 the father-son team henry and
lawrence bragg were the first to
describe how to interpret the x-ray
diffraction pattern
[Music]
they used a sodium chloride or salt
crystal for their experiments
later the bragg's mentored many
world-class researchers who used x-ray
crystallography on a variety of
increasingly complex substances
[Music]
in 1958 using x-ray crystallography john
kendrew determined the first atomic
structure of a protein myoglobin
with that the field of structural
biology was born
more and more scientists started to
study the 3d structures of proteins and
by the early 1970s there were a dozen
atomic structures solved in different
labs
researchers around the world were
interested in exploring what these 3d
structures revealed
however data sharing was difficult in
the time before the internet
early pdb structures were stored on
paper punch cards
each containing information about one
atom
the protein data bank archive was
established to solve this problem
the scientists deposited the data and
the pdb copied it onto magnetic tapes
and distributed them to researchers upon
request
in october 1980 10 years after the pdb
was established the pdb
archive holdings contained 151
structures available for distribution
the following year the first dna
structure was added to the pdb
in 1989 the first structure determined
by a biophysical method called nuclear
magnetic resonance spectroscopy
or nmr was deposited to the pdb
in this method a purified protein is
mixed with special solvent and inserted
into an nmr probe
the protein sample is then exposed to a
strong magnetic field
this makes the nuclei of certain atoms
like hydrogen spin like tops
when the sample is probed with radio
waves the nuclei become excited and
resonate the frequencies are measured
and recorded
the surroundings of the atoms determine
how high or how low the frequencies are
using computational methods the
measurements are converted into a graph
that represents the frequencies as peaks
with specific locations for specific
atom groups
this information is further refined and
combined with additional nmr experiments
to determine the 3d structure
the nmr method proved to be effective in
solving 3d structures of smaller
proteins
and gave us a unique glimpse of how
proteins behave in solution
in 1991 the first structure determined
using 3d electron microscopy
or 3dem was released by the pdb
in this method a tiny amount of purified
protein is placed onto a copper grid
[Music]
a special machine spreads the sample in
a single layer on the grid
the sample is frozen in liquid ethane
and then loaded into an electron
microscope
the sample is exposed to a beam of
accelerated electrons and
images are captured
usually the proteins are in many
different orientations
the images are then grouped by
orientation and then combined
computationally to reconstruct the 3d
shape of the molecule
atoms are fit into the map to derive the
3d structure of the protein
3dem has become a perfect complement to
x-ray and nmr techniques
the method is very effective on large
complex assemblies that are typically
difficult to study by either of the two
older methods
in 1995 the pdb archive became
accessible for the first time through a
www website
the pdb holdings were accessible online
through various services since 1988.
however the new website equipped with a
browser marked a new chapter in data
distribution
researchers could still request the full
archive on cd-rom in 1999
the 10 000 structure was released into
the pdb
the distribution of the pdb archive on
physical media was discontinued in 2004.
by then the internet and computer
technology made it possible for all data
operations to be done
completely online through the ftp server
and web portals maintained by the
members of the newly established
worldwide pdb
organization in 2008 the pdb archive
reached another milestone number of
entries
50 000 structures in 2014 the number
doubled
as the pdb entered its golden year there
were more than 170 000 structures in the
archive
the growing numbers of 3d structures of
proteins and nucleic acids further our
understanding of biology and help us
explore how life works at the atomic
level
many nobel prizes have been awarded for
projects involving molecular structures
structural biology research is essential
in addressing major public health
emergencies
for example scientists have used the
structures of hiv proteins to design
drugs that stop the virus from
multiplying
today as the world faces the covid
pandemic
structural biologists are exploring its
viral proteins in a quest for new
therapeutics and vaccines
the pdb provides ready access to
structural biology research
ensuring the quality of the data and
providing tools for query
visualization and analysis of these
structures
now 50 years since the pdb's founding
the protein databank continues to be a
leading global resource for experimental
data that is playing a central role in
scientific discovery and education
[Music]
you